[Music]
these kids look like they're having a
good old time the ballroom spin-off
doesn't premiere until October but only
we can reveal the show's new hosts past
Dancing winner Jordan Fisher and his
former competitor Frankie Muniz are the
emcees of the new show when they finally
called that it was happening I was so
excited because I had such an amazing
time on Dancing with the Stars and I'm
so glad to be doing what Jordan is we
have so much fun together and it's gonna
be awesome
full cast will be revealed in September
and all the kids are connected to show
business
it's Dancing with the Stars as you know
it it's a stage that you're familiar
with that you love but it's brand-new
Frankie and you're don't have kids
themselves but say the new show will
appeal to everyone it's the same show
it's the same feeling of sitting down
and watching people compete in something
that they've never done before most
recent champ figure skater Adam rip on
Val Chmerkovskiy and Emmy winning
choreographer Mandy Moore are the
celebrity judges
Mandy created the dances for lala land
and actually taught me the moves big
step goal one two yes the two new house
went on the dancing tour and say one of
the hardest things for the kids to learn
is dancing in front of an audience
before every show is still petrified
kids
[Music]